And does,
we know,
we'll look at the usual preprocessing
steps that we go through to take some text
data in its raw form and
put it in a different form,
which is more amenable for
a neural network processing.
So, um, what is texts really?
What is the raw form for
a actual text? Uh, well,
really it's,
you should think of text in its raw form
as just a long string that contains all
of the characters that, uh, that are
contained in a contained, in the text.
So we have an example here where we have
just a single sentence represented as a
long string, uh, but it
could be a whole webpage. Uh,
so the textual content of a webpage
where the whole string would be, uh,
all the sentences, uh, in order
that they appear in, in the,
uh,
in the webpage and question.
So that's the raw format for our text
data and that we'll see a bunch of steps,
uh, preprocessing steps that we
usually go through to get, uh,
to represent this text in a format that's
going to be easier to manipulate when
we want to feed textual
data. To a neuro network. Um,
so the first thing that we usually
do is that we will tokenize the text.
That is, we will identify essentially
the words or tokens that are, uh,
present in, uh, in the, in
the text itself. So, um,
so for instance, for this sentence here,
he spending seven days in San Francisco,
then we could split it, uh, like this. Um,
so the first token or word would be heat.
The second one would be apostrophe
s then spending seven and so on.
So we'd convert that into a list of
shorter strings where each train is a word
and, um, uh, instead of
word, we often say a token.
So for me, the data sets, if you download
the data, set a NLP Dataset from the web,
this step as often been
done for you already, uh,
but if you were to apply this on where
you would extract by yourself some,
some text data from
the web point instance,
you would have to go through that
step, uh, for English and for French,
usually just splitting words
or tokens based on, uh,
by essentially spinning at spaces
and also separating punctuations.
So,
for instance,
we notice here that the a.here a is
actually a separate it as its own token.
And if there had been a Camo so it
would be considered its own token. Uh,
so if we just use these two simple
rules separate at spaces and make
punctuations their own token,
then for English and French,
that usually works fine. And
we've been able like this to, uh,
essentially separate
everything into words.
It's not as much true for other language
before English and French that works
well. Uh, and there are some other
languages where that works well.
But we have an example
here where our points,
maybe what we would want actually is
consider San Francisco as a single word,
a single token and a,
if you wanted to do some more
fancier preprocessing like this,
you need to define some rules.
Uh,
where are you would identify
that a space here for instance,
is not something that should
separate that token into two. Okay.
But just keep in mind and in general,
just separating by species
is often sufficient. Uh,
in particular for English and French.
Um,
next,
we often limitizing the tokens that it
will put them in some sort of standard
form where we remove some,
uh,
usually syntactic information that is
contained in the words. So for instance,
we could take the word he and
just remove the capital letters,
so uncapitalized it,
or we could also take some verbs and
actually put them in a more standard form.
Uh,
we could take numbers,
it just replace them by
some arbitrary token.
Here I chosen the token number,
uh,
just to say that this was a
number and a pass this step,
you just don't know which number it was.
Um,
we could remove plurals or
days converted today and so on.
So the specific kind of limits ization
that you might want to do for a
particular problem, we'll, we'll vary.
Essentially what you want to do
is remove variations of words, uh,
that are not relevant for
the task you want to solve.
So if knowing that this is seven,
this is just an arbitrary
number is important,
then you'll want to keep seven
here. Uh, in the same way, if, uh,
knowing that over, uh,
uh, now noun for instance,
was singular or plural is important,
then don't remove the plural.
Just keep it in its original form,
in the original text.
Okay.
So that's the monetization.
And then what we'll do is that,
uh,
will not convert ev all of these tokens,
which are strings into an integer id.
And the way we'll do that is that
will first come up with a vocabulary,
uh, which is a list of words that we're
willing to recognize, advanced English.
And, uh, so this vocabulary,
we can think of it as a big long
lists of words. And then, uh,
once we've made up this list
and we can associate, uh,
each word in that list or each
token, uh, to a unique ids offense,
the first one could be id one, the
second one, I need two, three, and so on.
Um,
so how did we come up with that list of
words that are different criteria that
we can use?
Uh,
we can just pick the most frequent words
in the data set that we've collected.
Uh, so we take all the words to
have a frequency of at least five,
or if we want to limit
the number of words,
if we know the number of words
we willing to, to distinguish,
we could say we'll take the
100,000 most frequent words.
So that's a very general, which is
often used sometimes. Also we, uh,
decided to ignore some quote
unquote uninformative words, uh,
which would define using a short list.
For instance,
we could remove articles
like the or, uh, uh,
there might be other words which are not
useful to recognize in the text for the
problem that we want to solve.
And at Dnh then for all the
words or tokens that are not in,
not in our vocabulary that we've defined,
uh,
then all of these other words will be
mapped to a special out of vocabulary id.
So at the very end of our list, we can
think of it as there being an extra word,
Oval v four out of vocabulary.
And then this one will take a,
the last id in our list of,
so if I had a say here,
I had nine words, then this
would take id, 10 points things.
Yeah.
So again,
depending on the problem,
the type of vocabulary we want to define
the rules that we want to choose for
selecting which words we
want to distinguish and
associated that are unique id
to a is going to vary.
Um,
and in practice the vocabulary size
can actually, uh, uh, be quite big.
It can be as little as around 10,000
or as high as ton and a 50,000 or even
more.
Yeah.
So here's an example of the
last preprocessing step.
So we have this list of tokens
that have been limitizing.
And then imagine I've defined
this vocabulary here where
the is associated with
the ID one and two,
two and so on until Oh v,
which is associated with the ID five.
Then I take that and I replace it by one,
the integer one,
because the has the id one
and cat in the list, uh,
is not present. So we'll map
it to the idea of [inaudible].
So that's why we have five here than,
and is going to take the ID to uh,
the one again.
And then dog, she's a,
which has the ID three,
it's going to be associated
with three and so on.
Yeah.
So, um, um, for the rest of the videos,
uh,
w whatever we're going to refer to some
word ideas often I will use this symbol
w um,
so we can think of w as a cartographer
categorical feature that describes the
original word.
It's essentially a feature
description of the original words.
So fun since the,
we can think of one as being a feature
and it's a categorical feature because it
corresponds to which category in many
categories where each category would be a
different word in the vocabulary.
So to which category does
the correspond to and uh,
we could imagine adding
other features and that's,
we'll probably talk about
in the following videos. Um,
but at this point now we
have data which is taking a,
a format which is more numerical,
so that's going to be easier to deal with.
And, uh, still sometimes when I'm
going to talk about and refer to WWE,
I might say the word w, even though
really it corresponds to an id,
but because it's just at this point,
these categories correspond Duker
respond to individual words,
except for o v which correspond to any
other word that's not in the vocabulary.
So, um, you know,
talking about WWE as a word is
not such a stretch really. So,
um,
so that's a 40 preprocessing,
and that's the kind of preprocessing
we'll assume that has been done for the
data, uh, for everything else that
follows in the next [inaudible].